oh okay that's better
hi everybody my name is Brian scarf I am
the analytics director for the Kaiser
Permanente Northwest regions health plan
in hospitals and joining me is Delilah
Moore who is the manager for our
pharmacy analytics team them so we are
happy to be here I see some familiar
faces and a lot of new faces and spend
the next hour talking about analytic
careers in healthcare organizations and
we're going to use a one of our more
recent projects which is using the
Oregon emergency department information
exchange system and we've obtained a
data feed from that system and we're
using it for analytic purposes so we
will use that as our example to walk
through how analysts work inside our
organization
so overall full open up we'll talk a
little bit about analytics and
healthcare as a whole and analyst roles
and healthcare organizations and then
we'll I'll provide a brief overview of
the Eddy system and what it is and what
it does we'll talk about of how the
analysts analyst roles contribute to our
project obtaining Eddy data and we'll
talk about some of the how we're using
any data for analytics inside Kaiser
Permanente and we'll end with some open
Q&A give you time that's any questions
you might want to of us and we'll be a
shameless plug for our summer hybrid
course at the end of the agenda so with
that I will let Delilah open up our
conversation sure analyst problem that
dipper Mercer okay good hello mom can
you yes guys hear me
okay come on okay cool
so everyone said my name is Delilah
Moore I am the pharmacy analytics
manager at Kaiser Permanente health plan
I've been with Kaiser for just over
seven years I started kind of as a level
two analyst and worked my way up to a
level three and then a level four
leading a team and now I manage a group
of analyst so both Brian and myself were
analysts ourselves at one point in time
so we understand kind of the nature of
the work and now we both kind of oversee
and lead teams of analyst so what is
analytics you can see there's a
definition up there systematic use of
data to discover business insights to
apply it
analytical disciplines leading to
fact-based decision-making for planning
management measurement and learning so
what does that really mean kind of how
that translates for us as an analyst in
healthcare so we might be asked
questions they could be using data to
come up with a descriptive analysis so
describing a certain population or
cohort of patients how old are they are
they mostly male how many diabetic types
wanting patients so describing kind of
the state of affairs we might also get
pulled in to do predictive analytics
we're doing more and more of that
especially after you kind of have a
solid data foundation we can kind of try
and get out in front of questions so
that we can be proactive and identify
patients maybe that are at risk of
developing a chronic condition so that
might be something that our leaders are
interested in trying to be proactive and
prevent patients from getting sick so we
might use predictive analytics to do
that or prescriptive analytics so using
analytics to come up with a
recommendation for a course of action
for the organization so kind of what
this means in healthcare for you know
someone in our department we might be
doing data analysis so we might this
might be an Excel spreadsheet this could
the you know joining tables in a data
warehouse pulling together different
types of information integrating data so
like you want to know who are current
members that are currently taking opioid
prescriptions and maybe they're diabetic
so we wouldn't having to pull different
information across various sources we
might be designing a metric so taking
data from its raw state putting some
business rules around it and then coming
up with something that we can measure on
a monthly or yearly basis to track
progress we might be creating reports so
my team does a lot with tableau during
data visualization coming up with trend
graphs charts showing our business
partners you know how are I'm going to
probably give a lot of pharmacy examples
because that's my world but you know the
cost of high specialty medications
trying to stay out in front of the trend
just keeps increasing it keeps costing
more money so we might create reporting
to track that it also could include
dashboards or scorecards that's a big
part of what our team does - pulling
together a lot of different metrics into
a dashboard business intelligence so our
team also does a lot of Cognos
self-service business intelligence BI
kind of reporting and then as I said
predictive analytics text mining we've
had pockets of this so you know trying
to mine information out of progress note
or complaints database where everything
is just that hand keyed in free text so
trying to put some structure around that
to make some insights so I can go so
really what an analyst does we're trying
to connect the people with the
information so that would be you know
the person out in operations that has
the question you know and they need data
to be able to inform their decision
making so in order to do that
effectively these are kind of three of
the big types of general skill sets that
you need so programming skills that's
kind of definitely a foundation though
not something that you know you can
learn so if you're looking for
entry-level analytical
position you don't always necessarily
have to be an expert programmer this is
something you could pick up if you have
the critical thinking skills and the
communication skills but programming so
that could be we spent a lot of time
using sequel sass so writing code to
grab the data that we need from a
warehouse or some tables or combining
spreadsheets whatever it might be but
writing the code to kind of massage the
data into a form that can be published
as a report or an analysis and then the
critical thinking skills so that's
really essential just because you can
grab data doesn't mean that that's going
to help your business partner you have
to be able to be an active participant
in that decision-making with them so
just because you know how to be very
technical and get the information you
also need to know what to do with that
and how to take it from a point where ok
it's numbers in a spreadsheet to
something that ok well this is actually
something that's going to help me figure
out what I need to do next so it's that
type of thinking skills that are
critical and then communication skills
so again this is also very important
because as an analyst we tend to be very
technical people so being able to
explain a very technical thing to
someone that's not technical it's really
important in our field so this slide
just has a couple of examples of some of
the types of questions that might get
asked in healthcare so in analytics and
our team so we actually have quite a
broad spectrum of areas in the
organization that we support so I'm with
pharmacy but we also support in patient
we do population health recording
financial reporting like our continuing
care services skilled nursing facility
hospice agents so these are just some
examples of the types of analyses that
we might get pulled in to do and trying
to think yeah and kind of on the far
right so the the financial performance
this one is sort of on the cusp at least
at Kaiser we have like dead
it's Financial Analysts that aren't
really part of our analytical team so
it's kind of a partnership if they're
looking to do something a little more
sophisticated they might come to us so
that we can join the financial data with
other data sources and maybe we get
pulled in to work on a business case if
they're trying to build a 24-hour
pharmacy and so it's kind of a
partnership but I just wanted to call
that out as a lot of organizations have
financial analysts but it's a little bit
different than kind of what Brian and I
on in our group of what we do yeah I
guess an example I just wanted to
highlight for the operational
efficiencies is one of the important
reports for our pharmacy leaders is we
call it member experience so this is
monitoring the amount of time that it
takes for a patient to pick up or to
show up in the pharmacy and the amount
of time they have to wait to get their
prescription and walk out the door so
that's one of one example of an
operational metrics that we track to
create efficiencies spend some time
talking about the high level what is the
organ emergence department information
exchange and just to fit some
backgrounds as we so we can talk about
how we're using that for analytics
purposes we call Eddy is a we like
acronyms and Eddy is much easier say
than emergency department information
exchange and so what is it it's a
real-time ad information exchange it's
used across all the hospitals in Oregon
and Washington
it is a intended to improve
communication and care coordination and
so that we basically it's a use any of
these primarily by the IDI doctors it
sends them it sends alerts about past
utilization facilities and flags if the
patient as presenting has more than five
or more edie visits in the past twelve
months for example or three or more
different
edie visits in the past 60 days and the
notifications are intended to be used
during the time when the when the
patient is in the emergency department
it's a push technology and it's designed
to basically improve
coordination of care for patients across
it may visit multiple emergency
departments across the across our state
or across the state of Washington
complementing the Eddy system is a pre
managed and pre managed is a
complementary product to Eddy that is
primarily used by health plans and the
primary care clinics group practices and
it's a it expands that real-time alert
notifications to a further upstream with
the intent of them basically we use it
to its we're able to use it for
notification for example when a Kaiser
member is admitted into an e d outside
of our service area we know that
triggers a need for care coordination in
the process of trying to bring make sure
that they're that if longer term care is
new that we're bringing them into our
system as quickly as possible and it's a
the pre manage the pre manage
notifications or we find to be very
useful for like eating navigators for
our telephonic Medicine Center which is
where we perform all care coordination
that takes place outside of our service
area so the pre managed side of Eddy we
is primarily its intended not for it's
not using the emergency department
itself but it's valuable for the health
plans and like like I said the clinic
sub or the mourn in the ambulatory
settings and why is why is this
important I mean for our organization
38% of our IDI utilization that occurs
at non kaiser hospitals so they're
outside of our they're outside of our
core hospitals in our service area and
this allows increased visibility to the
fact that one of our members is in a
needy and that's typically a trigger
point for care coordination needs of
it's particularly valuable as well for
Medicaid because the Medicaid expansion
we've recently experienced in the States
and Kaiser is part of health share of
Oregon and Medicaid is our Medicaid
Medicaid line-of-business has extremely
high IDI utilization so this is a way
for us to better manage that population
and try to try out new tactics to to
basically direct care to the place where
it is most appropriate and finally we
can avoid
expensive ad cost a lot of care taking
place in the emergency departments don't
need to take place in the emergency
department and for our system and the
model of Kaiser Permanente we can use
pre managed as a way to move that care
into a more appropriate setting so what
we're going to talk about briefly is
like that any system is a whole it
basically is like the way that the
system works is them the hospital's
patient presents the IDI it information
center - the EMR there's an interface
between the EMRs and the vendor is
called CMT that manages the Eddy system
additionally the health plan send
membership data to the Eddy system so
we're joining the emergency department
activity at the time it's taking place
with the health plan core membership
information and what we just talked
about earlier was the kind of the alerts
guidelines the use of Eddy pre manage in
point of care what we really care about
them we're going to spend our time
focusing on from an analytic perspective
is we've we've initiated an extract on a
nightly basis of the encounter data
through Eddy into our regional data
warehouse so what that means is today we
have a data file of all of our IDI
utilization from yesterday this is a big
improvement for us because typically to
get to a complete IDI utilization
picture we have to wait 90 days for a
claims run out because we pay external
IDI utilization for claims so we've gone
from a 90 day 90 day flag to a one-day
leg so we improved our data relevancy to
89 days which is a huge improvement so
what we're going to focus on is talk
about like the process of getting the
data into our organization we'll talk
about how the analyst analyst roles
contribute to that process and then
we'll talk about how we actually use
this data for analytics so I'm going to
take a couple minutes and just kind of
walk through the various analytical
roles that we have and kind of how they
translate and how they might be working
on the Eddie project so as you can see
here we've got spelled out too
analyst types so we've got a business
systems analyst and a data analyst and
really the business system analyst is
the closest to the front end application
so they need to understand how is the
underneath end-user interacting with the
system you know what are the fields that
they're entering into is this captured
discretely what is the workflow so those
are the types of questions that they
need to understand and yeah the process
the business process involved that's
used to create the data and then so on
the eddie project they would need to be
close enough to what the system was
actually capturing and then as you move
down to the data analyst this is where
things get a little more technical and
so this is you're taking the information
out of your source system and doing your
ETL extract transform and load your data
into a format that we can query it so
just because data is coming out of the
system
in a raw form doesn't always mean that
it's easy for you to do something with
or to analyze so there's kind of that
in-between role of a data analyst to get
involved and work on putting together a
data model
maybe that's breaking out a raw file
into different star schema so that maybe
we want to do some business intelligence
reporting on top of it so they're really
kind of that technical data architect
that's laying that data foundation so
that the other analytical roles can do
something with it so that's kind of what
that role was needed with Eddie so we
could translate this data that we're
getting from that e system into our data
warehouse so that it would be easier for
us to join it with other sources you
know a health record number and you know
maybe it's a one row four table per
patient ok and then so we've got some
other analyst roles highlighted on this
slide so again we are in the bottom left
the data analyst so again there are
usually involved in most all projects
because having that solid data
foundation is critical to any
visualization or predictive analytics
you might be putting on top of it so to
the information analyst this is really
the type of analyst and myself
personally I've been I start
as an information analyst and I think of
that role as more of a consultant so
you're kind of sitting with your
business partner and maybe interviewing
them finding out what really are you
trying to get from this data what is the
business question what are you trying to
solve and so being able to translate
that business question into okay well I
can find that piece of information in
this table but in order to answer this
part about you know who's been a member
in the last six months we're going to
have to grab this other piece of
information so being able to translate
that business question into okay well
how do I find that in in the data and
what do I do with it
and then again it's the piece after you
get the data okay well how do I present
this back to my business partner so the
information analyst kind of sits from
start to end they don't get as technical
in the weeds as a data analyst that's
doing the ETL and pulling the data and
organizing it and architecting it but
they do have to kind of touch on all
those different pieces during the
process and then we have report analyst
whose main role is really to take the
data and create reporting out of it so
this could be an Excel graph this could
be a data table this could be a tableau
visualization it could be a Cognos bi
self-serve prompted report so really
taking the requirements from your
business partner and translating that
into some type of reporting and then
this slide it's a little bit hard to
read I know I didn't bring my reading
glasses them but details in here we
include mainly so you can deliver a
slides after the fact so if you want to
understand some the nuances of each of
these four analyst roles like this is a
good takeaway slide so yeah these really
are kind of the four analyst rules that
we have that Kaiser Permanente in our
department spelled out so again that
business systems analyst we put that
first because it's kind of closest to
your system and yeah they've got to
understand the process workflows be
connected closely and that's what your
end users to ensure that there is some
standard workflow in place so it's not
just
preform oh well they're doing it this
way and this other team is doing it that
way and then when you try and grab the
data and create a report it's just not
possible because it's not standard so
that would be kind of the role that
would help ensure that there's some
standard process in place in terms of
core skills
this could include process engineering
some systems configurations so they
might be making tweaks to the front end
of the application to ensure that the
data we get out is a usable knowledge of
business area so this might be you know
in our department we have a finance
business well we've got a business
systems analyst that kind of works with
our budgeting system and configures that
way so depending on what the system is
we may or may not have that type of role
engaged so examples of the work
mapping old processes to new so maybe
our old budgeting tool is going away and
we have to implement a new one so how
does the data translate from how it was
collected with the old system to the new
one it's not going to be probably a
match exactly so they might be
documenting that and coming up with
system workflow diagrams and procedures
so then we move to the data analyst
which again I think that's probably the
most technical of the rules that we have
on our team so they're organizing data
into information they might be doing the
ETL extract extract transform and load
coming up with native designs or
building out data marks to make it
easier for other analysts to grab the
data and yeah they are possibly building
business rules into a data structure and
ensuring data based quality those kinds
of things so the types of core skills
for this role would be medium to expert
SQL programming so you need to be able
to write code to get the data and you
know transform it into what you need it
to be from its raw form also skills
source and quality analysis logical
physical data models
and then usually SAS is the tool we use
informatica as well for some of our ETL
so those are kind of the core skills for
data analysts and yet usually the
projects they're engaged in or building
out data Mart so establishing that
common foundation that may or may not
have the business rules baked in to the
data and then moving into the report
analyst again this one is really focused
on the presentation layer so they're not
spending their time really I mean they
need to know how to code and to grab the
data that they need but they're not
spending you know they're not immersed
in the technical nuances the same way
that a data analyst would be so they
would possibly be creating reports
production reports maybe it's an ad hoc
report maybe it's an ongoing monthly
updated report that sent out either
automated or you know maybe it's
manually created and distributed by
email they could be creating dashboards
or scorecards tableau visualizations
anything of that nature
and then kind of some of the core skills
for this type of role medium sequel so
again they don't have to be a super
coder but they do need to understand how
to get the data and then knowledge of
one of the tools either you know Cognos
if they're going to be building out
reports and Cognos on the bi kind of
self-serve area or staff staff coding
staff had some capability to do graphics
and create reports and I hate to say it
but Excel is always a big one set you
know as much as I'd like to say we just
stick to these very elegant tools a lot
of times our end user just wants an
Excel report so that could be something
that having Excel expertise is always a
plus as an analyst and then moving on to
the fourth role information analyst as I
said this is one that I personally have
I've been in information in all instance
I've been with Kaiser the last seven and
a half years and its really kind of
interpreting the information being
involved in that decision-making making
sure that your business partners
the information in the data or the
visualization to make the decision at
hand so some of our core products
analysis they might be collecting
requirements either formally or casually
documenting business rules coming up
with ad-hoc reports so a lot of times an
information analyst might prototype
something and then possibly work with
the report analyst to say okay well we
need to do this on an ongoing basis but
this is kind of what we want it to this
is the mock-up of what we need and so
they might work with a report analyst to
make it into something that's scheduled
and running on it in an automated way
[Music]
yes and okay so core skills for
information analysts we'd say medium
sequel so this is really one where you
kind of take the question from start to
finish so it might be a smaller scale
project it's not like monumental of
building out a data Mart but it might be
okay well this is the question and we
need to grab the data figure out where
it is pulled together use SAS create an
Excel report put some visualization on
top of it and present it back so it's
again kind of not start to finish and
then staff skills SAS is probably the
main tool SAS and then we use Oracle
sequel developer to grab data and then
statistical background a lot of the
analysts in our team have statistics
backgrounds so if we're doing you know
more predictive analytics or a more
sophisticated maybe we're working with
our Center for Health Research and
partnering to evaluate a new program
that we just implemented so we might be
leveraging those kind of skills and then
I've got some examples of work listed
but if you have questions I can tackle
that at the end so we talked about how
high-level how we be like focusing on
the blue shaded area how the analyst
roles contribute to establishing a new
data source and learning how to use a
new system so now we'll talk about Eddie
and analytics for a little bit like for
the Oh past I'd say about a year year
and a half I've been extremely
interested in finding ways to leverage
the day
supported data sources inside the
organization there's a growing richness
of data managed by the states and in in
Oregon and Washington specifically and
then we we contribute to those data
sources but we really haven't taken
advantage of those data sources and for
value-added purposes inside our
organizations so we're trying to figure
out how to do so and I think Eddy has
been our first emerging success story I
said merging because we've only been
using the Eddy data since the up fourth
quarter of last year we established our
data feed in August of 2016 and it took
us a while to figure out to learn the
data and figure out what to do with it
so in a very high level I kind of walk
through and some of the basic data
aspects of what we are talking about
with Eddy so we have a I mean there's
basically a patient file which it gives
you the standard like name date of birth
member ID address encounter file so you
get to know the date the facility the
location like transfer event like how
does the patient arrive how the patient
leaves the encounter type was idioma
hospital service
chief complaint chief diagnosis of other
diagnosis codes attending physician and
a deceased flag and then finally as
historical utilization count'em this is
a relay flag as a Edie count in past six
months and inpatient counting past six
months so those are this is in all the
detail but these three slides comprise
the bulk of the detail what we're
talking about with the Eddy system so
the first thing we did is we had to try
to validate Eddie against our existing
data sources so we looked at making sure
like how much data is actually in the
Eddie system and how much is there is
there are we still missing data or how
reliable is it so we validated during
the third quarter and what we found is
there were ten thousand roughly 10,500
of encounters that we found an Eddie
that were also in our existing inpatient
data Mart
there are about 2900 that were only in
Eddie that were not in our data Mart and
these would be folks that have for
various reasons the membership status
was was not appropriate
and finally there are about 3,200 that
were in our KP and patient data Mart
that we're not in the Yeti system and
what we discovered is there are still
hospitals not using Eddie um there's
some small ones around the states that
are not using the Eddy system so there
are a few that fall out but by and large
the vast majority we were capturing so
it was a it's not a hundred percent but
it's good enough to use for analytical
purposes and so once we we spent about a
quarter learning the data profiling the
data figuring out how we could use it
and then we came up with a couple core
uses 'im so the first the first we did
was a needy daily census report I guess
it earlier is like in historically to
get a fully accurate IDI count it took
about 90 days because we'd wait for the
full claims run out to a car and we with
Eddie we have a day after data file and
actually we're capturing two data file
the day after and then one week after
because where our theory is that some
hospitals might be have interface lags
and whatnot so them but what we do is
we're using this to create a Edie
leading indicator status say how many
how many people how many Kaiser members
were in the emergency department
yesterday so Eddie is being used to
supplement our existing at the clarity
data and we're basically bringing in the
encounters from we're using Eddie to
bring in encounter some external
hospitals that we don't have a direct
feed to within our clarity environment
and there's a few of our core hospitals
that are non Kaiser hospital that we
actually do have those feeds so the
impact for us ilysm near real-time
visibility to total IDI hunts us across
all of hospitals and it the big
improvement was that reduced claim leg
from 90 days to one day so what does
that look like and here's kind of our
simplified explanation of how we did it
our model ISM the data Mart layer we use
clarity plus claims as our core in our
data Mart tab so that still stays in
place and then we added in the Eddy
layer as a supplement as a new
information source and we use the
connect combination to create the IDI
leading indicator so to walk through
what that looks like let's say if for
for encounters and we found encounters 1
2 & 4
in our existing data Mart layer meaning
they were in a Kaiser hospital or we had
a feed and then we found encounters two
and three in Eddy as well so we take
encounters one two and four from our
primary source which is our epic
environment or our claim are our ADT
feeds and then we use Eddy as our
supplemental source that we captured one
additional encounter so we have a more
complete picture of what's happening to
our members in more real-time which is a
very valuable for monitoring of like
monthly performance as trends and they
say how are we doing with our with our
Hospital is our IDI utilization on on
forecast or web of forecasts are we
below forecast and it lets us basically
make more more accurate decisions in a
more timely manner and gets real quick
in case you didn't know clarity is the
data warehouse behind epics EHR thank
you second this was a new use this is
not one of our planned uses but it's one
that we've been asked to ask to create
and so I can't tell you the impact yet
because like says brand-new it's being
developed right now but again we're
using any to supplement clarity data the
operational bounce-back report is
basically like people that are bouncing
back to the IDI and we're again just
like the census we are using we're using
a Eddy to provide a more accurate
pictures like we had very accurate
information for our to Kaiser emergency
departments that we run because we it's
our system but we're able to use them
what we're able to do now is supplement
our Kaiser hospital today de with Eddie
to provide a more real-time more
accurate more complete picture of ET
bounce-back because it's like someone in
theory could go to Kaiser Westside
hospital Edie and then two days later or
even sometimes even the same day go to
st. Vincent's on the same day and we
would know about the Kaiser activity
what we wouldn't necessarily know about
st. Vincent's activity so this provides
us ability to to capture both and those
bounce back reports are used bikes and
the care coordination teams to make sure
that if we see someone showing up
multiple times there's a sign of a
problem and something more needs to be
done so they'll be outreach to and then
I'll that'll trigger a series of a
of care coordination events and this is
another new source and we're going to
start using the Yeti system or the ID a
data feed for basically IDI source
document them so what that is is like we
we know from claims when the day at ETV
it occurred but we for outside
utilization we never knew the time of
day that that visit occurred so using
the eddie system we now know the day and
the time that occurred and what that
allows us to do is it allows us to piece
together the total picture of care so if
a member called us before going to the
emergency department we now we know not
just that a member called us on the
phone called regional advice
maybe we went to Urgent Care and the
emergency department we know the
sequence of that event so that time
stamp out of Eddie proved to be very
valuable we weren't anticipating that
but them from an analytic perspective it
allows us to piece together the series
of events on the days that our members
go to the emergency department and we
can use that to look for trends and spot
opportunities to intervene or create
better care pathways so our goal with
this is to identify upstream
intervention points and we can redirect
care to more appropriate settings it's
in use right now but it's still too soon
to tell the results so but this is a
another unanticipated reasonable use of
this data and the final use of the data
and that's another new one that we we
just thought of about a month ago is
then we're going to it's a new request
we actually get a new data file for this
but we're going to get a historical EB
utilization for new KP numbers from the
Eddie data system so when new members
are joining our organization and if
there was a history of high e d
utilization in the past twelve months we
know that means that there's care
coordination is required or a greater
level of outreach is required so what
we're going to do is use the Eddie data
to identify proactively identify our new
members that need outreach and
enrollment into our care coordination
program so typically we wait for them to
either start showing up in the emergency
Department or from the call us on the
phone to make their first appointment
and we know for a lot of members they
won't do that they will either like
bills will catch it after they go to the
edy three or four times and say oh
there's a problem it but that's a lot of
that could be claims day so there's a
very big time leg as well so this allows
us to get a more more complete picture
and proactively outreach to those
members which is better for their health
and it's better for the it's better for
their cost is better for our cost is
pretty much better for everybody so
those are four examples them and this is
a I thought these were good to highlight
because one is like all for the analyst
roles in our organization serve a
purpose in creating this new value for
the organization and we're seeing some
really cool results coming out of it or
new ways we're creating new information
is like this isn't this is information
we haven't had in the organization
before so it's kind of a good example of
how analysts can impact a health care
organization finally our shameless plugs
have Delilah myself Shannon will be
again co-teaching this summer helped
data analytic entire course and
sponsored jointly by Kaiser Permanente
now Hsu it's a basically you get an
opportunity for hands-on coding a lot of
good discussions and we have a lot of
guest speakers from Kaiser Permanente
and leaders from two of our operating
regions of our new Seattle region report
land region and we have guests from our
program office in Oakland coming up to
them as guest speakers already confirmed
so the on-campus portion is August 21st
through 25th and we'd love to see and
the other plug we wanted to make is that
we have a few open or open analyst
positions at the moment there's one on
my team so we have an open information
analyst with pharmacy level 3 so if
anyone is interested in that I'd be
happy to chat with you after this we
also have them and if you searched on
the Kaiser Permanente jobs board is like
these jobs these titles you see that we
just used or what they show up as on but
we do have this little I mentioned the
pharmacy analyst we have a an analyst
and utilization management one in
population health
we're recruiting for right now so and we
have our summer internships coming up
soon which I believe we have three
graduate level internships coming up
this summer and those always typically
post in the early April timeframe so
with that we want to save some time for
questions we have about 20 minutes so
we'll open the floor to hear from you
sure yeah so we spent about a quarter on
that effort and what we did in this
situation was a basically using
encountered data coming in through the
Eddy systems like we we spent a
significant amount of time as like
basically matching to claims to either
the claims or for our internal to we we
own two hospitals so for our two
hospitals we matched it directly back to
the encounter data we have an epoch M so
this was a process I mean it's not
foolproof but it's a we were basically
matching from patients member ID last
name first name of encounter date
facility I'm just to understand like
step one is understand the data so it
was like are we getting one record in
Eddy for every four proclaimer or
potentially hospitals entering
transactions multiple times and we have
to create some logic to filter down in
this case there was some dirtiness to
the data coming in so there were cases
where there were multiple records are
like an update after the fact would
trigger a new Oh a new fire in Eddy so
we basically use that as create some a
lot I mean its crude right now but it's
a basically logic of them if it's
basically the same encounter record we
take the most recent data file and that
becomes the one we use for analytic
purposes and we always basically bring
in we start out bringing everything in
and don't apply any logic and we just
work with the raw data for a period of
time until we understand what its how
its behaving and then we'll start adding
logic on after after about a quarters in
this case it took us about three months
before he started adding any logic on to
that process
we have a wearable devices and
broad-scale we have not yet and we we
have pilots underway in our southern
california region they were trying to
figure out the best way to use that data
in Northwest we have not done that yet
and we do have instances where we are
the patient questionnaires being
completed through my charts item we are
we are using and we have other external
debt like Delilah had a project refused
post office data for part of mail-order
pharmacy analysis this year we have them
like our member surveys and so there's
some external data sources we're trying
to one of our goals is to try to
establish more external data feeds to
complement what we have internally which
M we have the eddie project right now we
are approved on a very limited basis for
use of organ a PAC data for new member
onboarding which is another very
significant learning taking place right
now but is it relates to like wearables
or home devices like that I think it's
we're not at full scale yet them but the
organization ISM I think we it's pilots
are underway in our research areas I
think the closest thing we have we have
exercises a vital sign is like a
questionnaire and we ask patients you
know how often they're exercising so we
have at least something but yet not
quite there yet
you license an easier generation
software other providers we up to this
point we have not well there are weight
and there's always a topic of
conversation quite frequently and I was
like there are there are instances where
we have a pretty tight network
integration like in this in this area
that like kiona Portland clinics work
very closely together so we've talked
about it as how far we take that model
for for our network our contracted
network partners but is like a it's like
a commercial venture as like the
organization's decide that's
we don't get into those types of
ventures and we're focused more on them
when we do when we do release to the
community typically from a community
benefit perspective and it's like just
released as an open source to the and
we've done that frequently with research
studies and some of the algorithms
developed in our research organization
but as it relates to data Mart design or
an is like the data infrastructure we
haven't done that yet
Wow that's a good question
a typical request so something that we
might shout shut down and say no way
that's what we could you get some weird
ones the worst are related the lawsuits
I would say because it's something bad
happened and I think that's a more
recent one is and it's from our
community benefits and this will be a
typical I think and but we're hoping to
shift more to typical because as part of
our organization Commission is on the
Community Benefit side and we have a
program called driving schools and so
I'll actually created the first
dashboard or series of reports for them
and the David Douglas school district
was working with us and they they wanted
basically population health metrics for
their school district top their Kaiser
population and they're using it for to
go after a grant to open a community
health clinic in the high school so it's
really cool use of our data outside of
our walls but and kind of extending our
reach into the community but I would say
that's a typical just because it's like
outside it's a school district number
one it's not a health care provider and
it's a kind of a unique use of our of
our data I think more typical would
probably be like we just get me with
oodles of requests for like I need a
population of XM or how many people we
had one yesterday and how many Medicaid
members are using our new eugen clinic
we get lots and lots of those like very
like low complexity but high volume type
of requests it's just them slice giving
a counts for a population count for like
three or four different variables yeah I
mean for me atypical requests are around
what drugs people are taking and that
usually translates to list the patients
that a pharmacist can outreach to and
convert from a non formulary to a
formulary product I mean those are not
very sophisticated well they can be
actually if the patient has allergies
and there's a lot of different data
complexities with pharmacy data but yeah
and like who's taking the most expensive
medications what providers are
prescribing the drugs that we don't want
them to so those types of things rolling
things up by
provider or medical office that's very
common so that you know our leaders can
understand well as their one medical
office that's a poor performer and we
need to get out there and work with them
so that's kind of typical stuff and I
would say it's a typical really when the
business partner comes to us and asks
for something really cool and predictive
analytics or statistical that doesn't
usually happen rose through that ends up
being okay here's the question that
they're trying to address and then they
might come to us and we might say oh
well maybe we could use this cool
technique so they don't usually come to
us and say I've got this cool idea
and the hospitals would get a lot around
patient flow and date/time stamps as
well or in the ambulatory side of them
access measurements like how many times
an appointment cancelled before a member
showed up or did the member cancel it or
the fake provider cancel or trying to
understand those different types of
behaviors and anything looking for waste
on that operational side is fairly
common oh speaking of ways your company
operates in the District of Columbia do
you do military or government
contracting we do not have military
government contracting and but we the we
do serve a lot of our federal employees
our Kaiser members but you don't um do
work for the VA for example there's I
think there's limited referrals back and
forth but a Kaiser does not participate
in TRICARE
it it feels like it's a losing battle
sometimes it feels like we've we've
taken the approach I mean whenever we
build a data Mart and particularly
whenever we have self-service tools on
top of it and number one we try to build
a lot of safeguards into the into the
self into the BI tool to prevent people
from doing things they should an exam so
we build a lot of them the business
rules into the data layer so that the
metrics are pre calculated or that they
they can't be calculated incorrectly
using the self-service like analysis
tools or the ad hoc query tools them and
the a lot of our business rules as to
the metric definitions calculations
right now are captured in embarrassingly
shaped like Word documents Excel makes
SharePoint of our organization at an
enterprise level is if two efforts that
are in their emerging phases right now
one is around them true data governance
inside the organization so we have them
we have twelve data to twelve data
stewards them that are at a national
level governing sorting to govern the
data domains that we use on pharmacy is
going to be the first implemented effort
so Delila will be heavily involved with
that them how we relate them in for us
and to have them like eight operating
regions with eight slightly varying
definitions of every all the various
metrics we have one pharmacy system but
it's not entirely used 100% the same
from a workflow perspective so how a
national governance effort unfolds is
yet to be seen I mean we can talk about
that next year's talk because we'll
learn a lot during the course of the
coming year compliments I be analytic
community we have an effort underway
right now to build a a single and quite
robust knowledge management system for
the analytic community so a common code
repository com
request management like analyst analyst
directory so that we can start to
integrate what analysts are completing
what requests what requests are using
what code what code links to what data
sources them as that takes hold I think
will be immensely powerful and it's
going to become an entire new
information source onto itself um so
where we are today and where we could be
four or five years from now and hoping
is a very different place and because I
think we are we're finally we as an
organization are investing and
systematically in that in those efforts
right now it's been very grassroots up
until this point other questions can try
to stump up sure
no my question really I mean I would say
that type of skill set doesn't live
within our group but there might be
other folks in the organization you know
whether it be consultants or you know
yeah I'm thinking like process
improvement type expertise might be if
they're you know working on a specific
project they might be getting some data
from us but then also supplementing that
with focus group interviews but yeah
that would not generally be an
analytical role but there are other
roles in our company that have some
mantle and skill sets but they're just
not analysts as they're fitting into
these four roles so yes it was VRT
inside
sure why not it's a again it's that's
another losing battle every time you add
an analyst you create about an analyst
and a half worth of demand because more
and more questions are created so I
think it's a we organizationally within
our region we we generate about 2500 new
requests per year for information and
some of them might be a four to eight
hour task some of those are nine months
tasks them so it's a very greatly and we
have a dual process where the big heavy
efforts or cross team efforts are
prioritized coordinated and prioritized
like top down and then we have a
decentralized method of prioritizing the
smaller requests within the operational
area ISM that supports a Delilah Delilah
basically manages the prioritization
processes for pharmacy but when it when
they need is requiring like pharmacy and
its Medicaid in its external data or
might go to one of our employer groups
and needs inpatient data so it's Benz
many areas those come to me and it goes
through like the top-down process as an
organization we are building like I
mentioned and we're building a common
request management and tool that will be
intended easily all of the analysts
across Kaiser Permanente we have about
2800 analysts in our organization so
it's a we have a huge analytical power
inside the organization as a whole
Windham right now there is no
coordination or prioritization across
those groups so and we are implementing
JIRA right now is our request management
tool and that should go live first
release we can be in about a month and a
half with four groups of us being one of
them and but the intent is over time
we're going to bring all of those groups
together and so that will give us
reporting and querying capabilities on
top of the requests and that will give
us a go to start to better coordinate
across the whole of the organization's
analytic capabilities and I would just
add one other tidbits about the
prioritization so we use right now where
using a SharePoint tool to track all of
our requests someone asks us we enter it
we've got a running list and then we
assign people as they have the bandwidth
and then kind of that last step is every
two weeks we have a meeting with our
pharmacy leadership to say okay here's
all the requests that came through which
one you know is this one legitimate you
want us to spend our time on this should
it trump these other things so that's
kind of part of the process too is
forcing them to decide okay how do you
want to use our time which ones are more
important than the others and sometimes
you know being that I'm pharmacy maybe
someone else in the organization needs a
piece of something from our team but our
pharmacy leadership says no you don't
want to waste your time doing that
it's not that so that is unfortunate
sometimes that you know you want to be
able to help everybody but it doesn't
always translate that way we are one
fast
thank you for attending I hope you found
this informative them we tried a
different approaches here so if you have
any feedback for us we'd love to love to
hear it either now or over email and
we'll stick around for a little bit if
anyone has any questions good and we
would have been scanning as I didn't
have crutches so that's why what's up
yeah feel free to take any extra food
that's back there thank you everybody
yeah thank you
[Applause]